John that's so cool how would you do
that kind of like motion blur this is so
much work we're gonna be looking at Old
Dune and new dude
[Laughter]
[Applause]
what is this
today's episode is brought to you by
expressvpn stick around to the end to
see how you can get three months free
when you sign up for a year
hey everybody welcome back to another
episode of visual effects artists react
Dune came out we all watched it we're
all Gaga over it I actually haven't seen
Dune I've been specifically not seen any
trailers because I've been wanting to
wait until I can see it in IMAX and I
haven't had that chance to yet so
hopefully I don't get anything spoiled
today well you over committed because
now we're gonna watch all the segments
on vfxrs react and you haven't watched
it yet okay I'm pulling a Clinton today
we're gonna be looking at Old Dune and
new Dune because old Dune is wacky it's
ambitious and it's super Jank
I'm very fond of the one from the 80s
because I saw it when I was like 12 or
13. and so when I saw it I was like this
is amazing and super scary and jacked up
I think it's a good film despite what we
might see today
sit back relax listen to that guy as he
does his Mongolian throat singing as you
uh get the blood of your enemies smeared
on your forehead and prepare for space
battle and let's uh let's Jump Right In
oh it's Willy Wonka
it's Willy Wonka versus Thanos
[Laughter]
in the world of Dune there's not really
any guns because everybody has these
personal Shields that will basically
stop anything that's high velocity from
piercing them however you can kill them
but you need to use a bladed weapon
where you get in close and you push
through the shield slowly you get the
knife into their Shield oh it's okay so
the shield is like a like a a glitchy
Aura so like real talk this effect isn't
that fancy looks like they just they're
doing these flickery things versus
outlining the person and literally just
taking that whole Roto layer of the
person tinting it red or blue sending it
to a low opacity some sort of transfer
mode and then glitching the position
just a little bit just like you can do
that all in compositing there's like no
3D work going on here yeah this is all
just nice hand animation basically and
honestly all of Dune the new Dune is
kind of like this where it's not that
the effects are like crazy technical
achievements except they're all so well
crafted by amazing artists the fact here
is a shot you can do on your home
computer it's about your art Direction
your touch as an animator it's not about
how crazy your tools are I mean maybe
there's some extra fancy tools involved
but really at the end of the day you
could sit down in After Effects you can
bust out this effect all right so that's
how they did the shields in the new Dune
how do you guys think they did it the
1984 version well they didn't have
computers back then it's funny you
mentioned that because when you see this
effect it's going to look very computery
very refrigerator like
wait wait wait wait wait wait wait wait
was that even Patrick Stewart's face or
was that a stunt double and they were
just hoping the Distortion would cover
that
that's Patrick's Day
Patrick has way more hair on the sides
of his head yeah
so that's why they had to blur it so
much because they put the camera right
in the face of the stunt double they're
like oh they won't tell the difference
those cubes they that's that's computer
generated though right that's like
actual it is not no it's not there's no
CG whoa
okay all right dude I'm excited isn't
that funny though it's like look CG
imagine it's 1983 and you're working on
this film and someone's like two
computer Graphics are so sweet I want to
have like CG block dudes for this scene
and everyone's like whoa whoa whoa whoa
whoa we can't actually render CG block
dudes like that over your footage yet
sir like we can't animate it to that
degree in complexity we haven't invented
the jpeg yet yeah jpegs don't even exist
so basically what they end up doing is
go all right let's reference what CG
images look like from the time but we're
going to hand animate and hand draw
everything in this scene yep well okay
so every single one of those little
cubes and squares are all hand drawn yep
yeah but what about the
whole so you know they hand draw all
these cubes on top of them and animate
them and then they're like all right it
still kind of looks junky that's how
they make a fancier and David Lynch is
like I wanted to distort the environment
so they're like okay and what they had
to do is they had to separate every
facet of these geometric Cube shapes
into separate plates so they drew the
cube and then you have to like make a
separate plate for the front of the cube
and you have to make a separate plate
for the side of the cube and you have to
make a separate plate for the hand part
of the cube and they'd print all them
one by one each facet of this Cube one
by one printed with an optical printer
that would basically just move and
distort the film plate for each facet it
took them nine months to make the
sequence that's fascinating what I think
is really funny about the scene what's
the point of having a shield that
protects your body like that if that's
how you look
that's why the new dude is better it's
like you turn on your shield and it's
there
but it's not like you can't see it all
the time you don't look like a freaking
like Roblox yeah
here's what we're trying to look at too
much I can't actually see any of the
choreography the reactions what's
happening although when his hands kind
of push through there at the end that
was pretty sweet
both films do very differently is how
the atrates family travels from Caledon
to Iraqis
so sunset on kaladan we're leaving our
home planet a new world away it's
they're traveling through outer space so
that's it this shot is the shot that
shows you they've traveled from one
planet to another yep that's it that's
also kind of like a classic film thing
which is you you don't want to like show
people traveling to places like they're
either departing or arriving and then
you don't show like The Hour of them
stuck in traffic right so Denise
Villeneuve amazing filmmaker but he
didn't have the guts to show a space
travel David Lynch was all about it
let's do it yeah
so just real quick mechanics of how this
works they load up other ships into this
giant High Liner I believe it's called
and the highliner teleports from one
spot to another and they can take all
their ships out of it and the Highlander
is piloted by a guild Navigator which is
basically a human being that has
consumed so much spice that they've
warped and turned into this weird
creature that can bend space and tire
they can see through space and time in
order to navigate these ships through
space and time so like Tabasco allows
them to teleport you guys go you got it
100 you nailed the capsaican yeah so
David Lynch is like I'm gonna show what
it looks like to travel through space as
a guild Navigator warps you with their
mind using one of these highliner
machines
oh oh it's her boy
so his name is Steve
you said the guild Navigators are human
it is a human
it was wasn't human it was it wasn't
human this is what the spice says to you
if you'd eat too much no we're going to
space now that we're going to travel
through space
decision to have them shoot light out of
their little undulating mouths
[Laughter]
[Applause]
[Laughter]
so it's so funny for the star facts it
looks like they got like water with like
fish food in it yeah I was gonna say it
looks like just a bunch of particulates
in water that they filmed against black
they're trying to get the like swirling
yeah
and now we're here
okay
after all that it's just like sir We've
ran out of Animation budget for the big
finale for the for the teleportation
scene they're like [ __ ] it all right
crank the opacity
so in the new Dune they just got rid of
this entire sequence and they're just
like hey big space hole just cut to this
shot basically minus the fading
man it would really suck to go to
arrakis after living on Caledon
we're going to the valley guys here we
go one thing they are nailing is
atmosphere which can get a little tricky
when you're doing compositing because
when you're doing compositing you're
bringing in elements from a bunch of
different things and basically cutting
them together in your program the thing
is getting that the light to play
correctly when everything should be at
different layers of atmosphere and get
really tricky because atmosphere does a
bunch of weird things sometimes it adds
light to things sometimes it takes light
away from things sometimes it takes out
certain colors but leaves other colors
like you can see how there's no blue sky
here for example the The Fog the dust is
actually catching light and scattering
it and kind of almost emitting glow as
if you're looking into like a cloud
exactly yeah because it's like when you
have a bunch of particulates in the air
and they're being lit up they're tiny
little particles that are reflecting
light from the source directly to you
and when you have it broadened out like
that it's essentially just a giants like
volumetric reflector
all right so we've seen where they
arrive on arrakis AKA Dune actually has
a super impressive shot take a look at
the shot I want you to tell me how they
did it
okay first off are all of the extras
real there in the on the I'm not telling
you you tell me you might have to go up
to the TV to be honest with you I think
everything is a map painting except for
the small group of people to the right
of the green flag there in the middle
and leading up the stairway there and
that's where it ends and everything else
is a matte painting go look closer go
closer I'm curious tell me that that's a
mad training go look closer whoa okay
first off I think they got some dummies
I think there's some dummies in that
shot because some of the people are
moving and some aren't wait what okay
okay hold up I think I think I that's a
miniature because there's a shadow over
the people underneath the thing so it
looks like the people and the miniature
spaceship are real at least physically
real okay so you got your miniature and
you got your real people so how do you
get both of those into the same shot
okay so if it's a miniature even if it's
a big miniature it's trying to replicate
the scale of something that's like a
football field in size so it's got to be
really close to the camera and there has
to be some sort of like cut out so that
any real people are off in the distance
unless this is a composite I gotta know
is this all done in camera 100 in camera
when you're looking at here is what the
film looked like when it was developed
because
they went and filmed this at a stadium
at Aztec stadium in Mexico they built a
huge scaffolding like 40 feet high they
put like the 10 foot big model on that
set and they have a little hole and
they're filming through it and through
that hole 250 feet away is the actual
doorway with the stairs and the people
with the flag the people are walking
down okay so it's not composited it's
just all done in camera
but so all of the people to the left and
right are those little those are all
dolls
[Laughter]
this is a miniature shot how come this
Vanishing distance and like perspective
in this shot if it's a miniature shot
how big how long does that mean a chair
is it 50 feet long oh those are other
Miniatures there that are actually
smaller they're forcing the scale a
little bit they're forcing the
perspective a little bit yep if you look
closely you basically if you look at the
lines of the runway on the right below
the ship you can see it stopped going
straight and tilt up and what they've
actually done is they've shifted like
the ground to like slant upwards to give
the impression of a Vanishing Horizon
Point those are just smaller ships
smaller dolls and the ground is slanted
up to make it look like it's going to
the distance but it's only a few feet
back so the crazy thing to think about
is like not only do you have to make a
cool miniature set but you didn't have
to build erect an entire scaffolding
system to make it split it up like 40
feet high with stairs and platforms and
cameras and also line up with another
real set that you built in the distance
like this is so much work but that's why
this one shot this is the best looking
shot in the entire film yeah there's
some incredible miniature work in the
original Dune so I've been working on my
uh my Mastery of the voice I'm gonna use
it on you here we go
leave a comment
now you're compelled right how dare you
use the voice on me
so I think one of the coolest things
that the new Dune got right is how they
designed the dragonfly-esque
ornithopters
their Acts actual dragonflies
dragonflies are
sort of ship designed after them like I
said I've been avoiding seeing any
imagery from this movie so this is my
first time seeing any of it and I love
it
they nailed the motion blur for high
speed movement like that like we're
talking like such high frequency of
motion that like in a single shutter not
only does it go down it goes back up and
back down and back up again and then but
it's catching the light there there's
one of their words yeah that shine uh
there's moments when it's catching the
light and exposing it well enough that
there's no motion blur just built in how
would you do that kind of like motion
blur like normally when you're doing
motion blur with visual effects you
would render out a like a vector motion
pass basically which is like your image
except it's a it's a rainbow in each
color corresponds to a different
direction and speed that things are
moving but when you deal with something
like this where it's moving so fast that
it would go beyond any value you could
possibly assign your motion blur it's
like you have to do it custom I wonder
how much of that flapping is a post
effect I don't know if the render
engines are actually good enough to
replicate that the way we're seeing it
because how many sub steps would you
have to have in order to be able to have
like that perfect
lots of sub steps a lot of sub sampling
I have a feeling that a lot of the
motion blur of the Wings was pushed
further in compositing rather than the
render stage I agree that's really well
thought out someone had to do a lot of
research into real dragonflies in order
to make sure that this shot looked as
cool as possible yeah hey real quick
let's show thefters in the 1984 version
I don't even remember them
there's no wings there's no wings they
realized early on that they tried to do
flapping wings and look really silly so
I don't know why
so next we should compare the scene
where the sand worm attacks the spice
Harvester and see the different
approaches they took with it so are the
worms the spice you got to chew up the
worms for the Spice the worms poop the
spice and you eat the poop
dude what is this story wait seriously I
mean that's not that weird alcohol is
just yeast poop I mean yeah fair enough
although I wonder how much you have to
how much do you have to drink to
teleport through space
it's called blacking out it's called
Black
[Music]
yeah wait hold up they nailed this this
shot is pretty sick yeah yeah they got
this one right wait oh dude
[Music]
it's kind of too bad it's all awkwardly
framed yeah
it's like so static they must have
gotten like really really really fine
powder yeah wow I'm actually I'm
impressed that's the first thing you
thought of because that is the hardest
challenge they had because you can't do
that with regular sand yeah it's like
okay we're gonna do
a scene uh can you bring in the
miniature sand
yeah
so it turns out they have miniature sand
actually yeah
really really fine powder is just really
really mini so it's actually little
micro glass balloons so there's a method
that you can make these like really like
microscopic glass particles hyper hyper
hyper dangerous to breathe so everybody
on set had to have like respirators and
goggles because the stuff gets in your
lungs it's it would cut up your lungs
and it would never leave it would never
leave your lungs oh my God so the reason
why I caught onto that Nico is just how
like fluffy the actual smoke looks the
actual like dust and smoke that's
hitting the air actually looks large
scale but it it can't be they can't have
some giant worm coming out of actual
sand so it has to be a miniature but in
order to get that sort of looking effect
the sand can't be real sand and you also
might notice there's actually the
cameras moving that shot so when you're
shooting stuff in miniature you want to
look big you have to shoot in slow
motion and they shot this sometimes at
120 frames per second sometimes at 240
frames per second it's filmed meaning
that film reel is spinning fast through
that camera just burning through that
film and almost bet there you see how
the worm bites on it after it explodes I
would bet those two things are supposed
to happen at the same time yeah yep and
in real life real life it probably
looked like it happened at the same time
but once you yeah yeah nailed it you
reviewed and you're like
it's like close enough I guess yeah so
you're telling me that there's a modern
version of that shop yeah a worm eats a
building oh yeah oh my God it's pretty
sweet Ryan you're into science right I
like science okay there's like a
phenomenon when sand you know how do I
say it if you vibrate it and pump enough
air through it it becomes liquefied
exact Perfection is the name of it it's
it's that liquefaction is a thematic
element of this film
[Music]
oh
yeah oh yes
I'm just getting like taking a lot of
inspiration from
not just awkwardly looking at a side
table I really like how they execute
this the shot and like it's really cool
seeing the similarities between 1984
Dune and 2021 Dune and like it's almost
the same shots and it's Soul it's the
same shot just like executed so much
with so much more excitement I love the
Bold choice just cover it up yeah with
the loading door
one of the coolest scenes is the Harkin
and Ambush scene at night and
specifically the crazy Shield bombs they
use
oh my God in the shield generator
finally like crashes and then bomb like
the explosion bursts out of it it's so
cool dude
it's so cool it's so good once again
it's like it's just a good idea it's
good art Direction well I just love that
idea like I did that a basic version of
that my uh satisfying render remember
the smoke thing that fills into this
yeah and like it's it's a thing where
it's it feels abstract until you're like
oh no in our world we can justify that
in our world you're actually gonna see a
contained shape fill up with an
explosion before like I don't know it's
it's so cool
foreign
we got a hostage situation because
today's episode is brought to you by
expressvpn that's right when you're
connected to an unsecured Network your
data out on the open internet is being
held hostage that's right hackers and
other Bad actors on the internet could
steal your data but with a VPN you get
that extra layer of encryption and with
expressvpn you get the best VPN service
that's out there but that's not all
Dunes the best thing that a VPN does is
provide me access to movies TV and other
videos that aren't available in my
region I use expressvpn to tell these
websites that I am in another location
and thereby get access to these movies
that I want to watch and the best way to
do that is through expressvpn it's rated
number one by CNET and tech radar it's
available in over 94 countries and they
have 24 7 customer service and it's
available on every device huge thanks to
expressvpn for always coming through and
sponsoring this show and if you are
interested in getting three months free
when you sign up for a year head on over
to express pm.com Corridor crew if you
don't know how to spell well guess what
just click the link in the description
below if you don't know how to click the
link in the description below well then
get off YouTube
and now back to Iraqis with the boys on
the couch
my takeaway from this is that there's a
lot of really cool ideas in June 1984
that I think just get marred by how much
work and effort it is to execute on all
these visual elements I feel like doing
1984 had a lot of inspiration for June
2021 so I'm glad it exists for that
reason I love all the art design it's
cool going back and seeing Miniatures
but the new Dune is expertly crafted and
I don't know if sci-fi can get much
better than that so it's just cool it's
really cool going back and forth and
seeing the differences and seeing how
much like Cinema has grown and how far
special effects and visual effects have
come thanks for watching everybody this
is a super fun episode we'll see you
guys in the next one Spider-Man 2 versus
Spider-Man 2 versus Spider-Man 2 coming
out soon